the correct spelling of my name is
pronounced Raven Symone well if you
learned something new every day yes
ma'am Raven Simone revealed the correct
way to pronounce her name on Tick Tock
over the weekend it's about truth and
honesty nowadays yeah and in the first
clip she makes light of it all
it's not
yes it is after receiving comments
saying she let this slide for too long
Raven then goes on to explain why she
never felt the need to correct anyone
yo people out here real mad that I never
said hey my name is Raven Simone and
you're watching Disney Channel no I
didn't do that because at a very young
age I was told to tell everybody my name
was Raven Simone and it just never left
my body except when I go to
french-speaking countries I'm like yeah
it is spelled that way and that's how it
should be pronounced but coming here to
where I'm living Raven Symone is just
fine Raven Simone makes it clear that
although she's setting the record
straight she's not making this a big
deal just fine so yes I don't trip over
it I don't correct people but the
correct spelling of my name is
pronounced Raven Simone but you can call
me Raymond Simone I'm not sure remember
it I'm down for the cause and bringing
in the New Year marks a huge milestone
for her the 20th anniversary of That's
So Raven earlier this month she shared
how it feels to receive so much love
years later obviously you have Raven's
home but don't you love how That's So
Raven has lived on on the internet with
memes and gives and everybody's they
find a reason to use Raven in every con
attack it's amazing how long this
franchise brand has lasted in the hearts
of the community and I'm so happy for it
and the fact that That's So Raven is
also a sentence is crazy to me now
where's my coin
let them know also one of the best theme
songs in Disney Channel History
[Applause]
[Music]
who sang it
out
[Music]